[Musique]
difficile de ne pas se mettre à danser
lorsque la musique est aussi rythmé le
violon et la danse voilà derrière ce qui
se trouve au coeur du festival métis
cette année l'événement a des airs de
grande réunion de famille où petits et
grands viennent passer du bon temps
[Musique]
c'est vraiment à propos de la peuplent
en pour vous c'est vraiment de faire
partie d'une communauté les
des activités culturelles c'est pour
prendre plus ce uniens et être ensemble
on peut dire que le peuple métis n'a pas
les pieds dans la même bottine legic
traditionnels sont impressionnantes et
donne à la fête des airs de réveillon
pour brianna lizotte c'est justement ce
qui fait le charme de sa nation cet
esprit de famille qui lui donne le
sentiment d'être toujours comme à la
maison nous sont chez moi chaque fois
que je participe à un événement de
l'action meetic chez moi et surtout est
la bienvenue
c'est pourquoi j'ai monté ma culture
l'alberta accueille le quart de tous les
mythes is du canada ils sont environ
cent mille à habiter dans la province et
ce peuple a dû combattre pour avoir sa
place dans l'histoire canadienne
certains de ses membres comme le plus
connu louis riel ont d'ailleurs dû
laisser leur vie dans cette résistance
mais aujourd'hui un siècle plus tard une
relève est toujours là pour chanter sa
fierté d'appartenir au peuple métis
[Musique]
tb
ici sébastien tanguay radio canada
edmonton